[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à strasbourg c'est parti pour 30
minutes d'actualité européenne
focus cette semaine sur la
présidentielle française
à bruxelles comme dans toutes les
capitales européennes les yeux sont
rivés sur les sondages
quelques mois après le break cité
l'élection de donald trump les chefs
d'états et de gouvernements craignent
une percée voir une accession au pouvoir
de marine le pen
un scénario catastrophe l'europe sujet
de clivage mais grande absente des
débats de la campagne on en parle tout à
l'heure mais d'abord direction bruxelles
justement là bas aussi la campagne bat
son plein un objectif rallier les voix
des deux cent cinquante mille français
de la capitale belge
reportage avec jérôme rabier bruxelles
coeur de l'europe et de ses institutions
regarde d'un oeil avisé la campagne
présidentielle qui se joue outre
quiévrain d'abord par une proximité
géographique et linguistique mais aussi
forte d'une communauté française qui ne
compte pas moins de 250 milles expatriés
un potentiel électoral que les
différents partis français tentent de
mobiliser comme dans ce café où les
partisans de benoît hamon compte faire
battre le coeur de la france y compris
au delà des frontières
ce soir au menu des débats le fameux
revenu universel mais aussi la
difficulté de mobiliser plus large que
la jeune génération et c'est pas
malheureusement des idées qui parle
vraiment
à nos parents ou des grands-parents et
comment est-ce qu'on franchisse 15
générationnel les personnes plus
installés qui en plus traverser la vie
ont énormément besoin de ne pas croire
que ce qu'on nous raconte c'est que de
l'utopie de la jeunesse entre guillemets
de long un public composé à majorité
d'employés des institutions européennes
on insiste aussi sur le projet européen
des candidats et une mobilisation
militante aujourd'hui pour benoît hamon
qui est extrêmement fort déjà levé 10
des jeunes actifs
il ya aussi des gens qui sont plus âgés
les réunions sont pleines et donc on
voit qu'à un mètre et y ait un intérêt
extrêmement profond t le fait qu'ils
montrent concrètement l'europe me fais
pas qu'on parlait il de manière pratique
et y couper pour ce bois pour que cette
europe change eh bien c'est un message
avec sam enfants pour les français
[Musique]
au delà de la base militante dans ces
communes du grand bruxelles où la
proportion de français est importante
les parties peuvent même se permettre
des opérations semblables aux sections
françaises aujourd'hui ses portes à
portes et opérations boîte aux lettres à
trois semaines du premier but et cinq
minutes pour la campagne électorale ont
fait le tour du quartier là et on
voulait vous donner des informations sur
la campagne de benoît hamon des gens
qu'il ya des propositions pour la france
et l'étranger coûte oui on est installé
en belgique en mai pour être forcée mais
ont une autre attention d'autres
occasions
tous les sens et en défense c'est un
[Musique]
autre forme de mobilisation le mouvement
réformateur belge parti libéral de
centre-droit a convié les représentants
des manuels macron et françois fillon
pour débattre devant un public à
majorité de français expatriés des
élections françaises
l'occasion pour eux de mobiliser leur
électorat comme tu le dis c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre de français
belgique en doutez vous être honnête
mais ils se sont très vite repris on a
pu les rassurer le président futurs
principes en partant pour le lapsus a pu
les rassurer
et aujourd'hui nous avons une communauté
française confiante
derrière le candidat françois fillon la
belgique
est extrêmement progressiste
/
disons qu'ils sont
le seul accompagnement également il y
avait
politique pour les studios et éminent
passerait très longtemps
yannick est un parti qui s'appelle le
mouvement réformateur martin
libéral il ya bien sûr qu'il y ait de
kelsen société de libéralisme économique
si l'élection intéressent évidemment les
expatriés les belges sont aussi friands
de la campagne française largement
couverte dans les médias francophones et
qui a tous les ingrédients pour les
tenir en haleine
ce qui me frappe c'est que les personnes
que je connais ne m'en parle tout le
temps preuve qu'il ya un intérêt évident
puisqu'il ya marine le pen qui
effectivement risque de sortir du
premier tour à la première ou la seconde
place qualifiés pour le second ce qui
serait tout de même assez historique
il y a les feuilletons de françois
fillon avec quelque chose qui est assez
invraisemblable à suivre presque au
quotidien je dirais et puis l'émergence
d'une personnalité étonnante comme
emmanuel macron encore inconnu du grand
public il y a un an ou deux tout ça
suscite un intérêt particulier pour
cette présidentielle française peu
importe le vainqueur
les belges eux regarderont ce résultat
on voit ça intéressait et guetteront les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir en
matière de politique européenne
[Musique]
alors comment nos voisins européens ici
au parlement voit-il cette campagne pour
en débattre andreas schwab bonjour vous
êtes député européen allemand vous êtes
membre du groupe ppe en face de vous
marc tarabella bonjour vous êtes
socialiste et vous êtes belge
bienvenue à vous enfin david carretta
vous êtes journaliste italien pour la
radio radical c'est bien ça oui j'ai bon
hockey marc tarabella peut être un mot
sur ce qu on vient me voir
cette appétence de des belges pour cette
campagne française c'est nouveau c'est
inédit où finalement vous êtes nos
voisins nous allons toujours regarder ce
qui se passe est un petit peu en france
on a toujours regardé ce qui se passait
en france moi quand françois mitterrand
est élu le 10 mai 1981 j'ai 18 ans et
avec mon père on pleure mais pas le
passionné triste pasqua ému de voir un
président socialiste en france donc
quelque part il ya toujours eu un
attrait parce qu'à une communauté de
langue et de culture évidemment parce
que celle de la france et un grand
voisin et que parfois ça influence aussi
peut-être sur notre politique est
complètement différente parce que nous
avons un système proportionnel où on
sait jamais trop qui gagne et qui perd
où il faut toujours être en coalition il
ya des gagnants et des perdants mais il
faut toujours être en coalition pour dit
j'ai dirigé alors quand francis est
majoritaire en tout cas jusqu'à présent
très clair où on sait qu'il ya une
élection et comment on va diriger
pendant cinq ans maintenant c'était 7
auparavant
et donc ça c'est plus clair mais sa
crise beaucoup plus aussi en france
puisque et comment vous voyez ça donc de
belgique cette campagne quand même assez
inédite somme toute sont très interpellé
moi je suis très interpellé par le fait
que et marine le pen et françois fillon
ont été cités parmi les favoris le sont
toujours probablement pour le premier
voir le second tour alors que ils ont
tous les deux les casseroles abominable
marine le pen au niveau européen at
utilisation de fonds pour tout à fait
autre chose que son assistance
parlementaire au niveau européen et
françois fillon le péno budget c'est une
honte
évidemment il ya la présomption
d'innocence c'est clair mais ici les
faits sont avérés c'est peut-être pas
illégal mais c'est amoral et donc il
devait se retirer il se retire pas il
met en difficulté son groupe c'est leur
problème mais bon on joue avec l'avenir
de français quand même pas un vrai à
saab
quand vous voyez la prégnance des
affaires dans la présidentielle
française
est ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourrait imaginer en allemagne bon le
système politique en france en allemagne
sont un peu différents non seulement en
ce qui concerne la proportionnelle et et
le besoin de trouver des coalition après
les élections mais aussi dans ceux dans
ce respect la nôtre chancelière est
connu pour un avis un mode de vie très
modeste donc ça c'est un peu des
traditions différentes ce qui
m'interpelle un peu d'un point de vue de
l'allemagne c'est que il ya beaucoup de
candidats -le qui sont connus pour des
positions plutôt extrêmes mais le débat
est un peu floue ou c quelques-uns qui
sont plus pour l'europe
beaucoup d'autres qui sont complètement
contre l'europe mais les débats sur les
détails
le débat par exemple sur le fait que la
constitution française à fait sûr que on
peut pas facilement sortir de l'euro
qu'on peut pas facilement sortir de
l'union européenne on n'en parle pas
donc effectivement débat sur leur après
un truc qui m'interpelle et je trouve
c'est regrettable car c'est quand même
comme le disait marc tarabella c'est
quand même le futur de la france qui est
en lan jeu est aussi un peu le futur de
l'union européenne comment on voit saad
a déclaré tu as depuis l'italie c'est
plutôt les affaires qui sont en premier
sur les gros titres ou ses demandes de
programme c'est marine le pen
potentiellement en tête au premier tour
qu est ce qui ressort de la presse
italienne pour les affaires en italie on
est des experts jeudi
90 2 manon lite on a eu silvio
berlusconi d'ailleurs démarre un nouveau
procès l'avait donc donc si je peux dire
quelque chose sur les affaires s'est
fait attention à déligitimer tout le
monde à faire des procès sur les
journaux on a vu les résultats en italie
les résultats ont été beppe grillo
berlusconi d'abord mani pulite tout de
suite après on a une belle housse
connais maintenant on à beppe grillo on
a les populistes de droite de gauche de
centre de haut en bas qui sont 50%
donc faites attention parce que les
procès sur les journaux au lieu que dans
lé tribunal c'est très dangereux parce
que vous dites c'est que cette prégnance
des affaires en fait plutôt que de
parler du fond et des programmes
conduits de toute façon à plus encore de
populisme oui surtout s'ils ont des
légitimes tout le monde en disant c'est
tous des pourris
le problème marine le pen est le disons
le problème qui est plus suivi avec deux
champs les pro marine le pen les contre
marine le pen le fait c'est que ces
élections présidentielles vont
déterminer pas seulement les le futur de
la france ils vont déterminer le futur
de l'europe si marine le pen mais pas
seulement marine le pen
même si jean luc mélenchon gagne
l'europe est finie et on oublie de le
dire très souvent en france en rappelant
qu'elles sont les mérites de cette
europe pour le moment c'est tout à fait
alors justement on a voulu faire un
petit peu un point sur les
positionnements de chacun des candidats
sur ces questions européennes qui sont
globalement à cette absente du débat de
la présidentielle
petit tour d'horizon avec salomé
rousserolles douglas
[Musique]
où est l'europe dans cette campagne
peu présente dans les débats c'est
pourtant un des principaux points de
clivage des candidats de cette
présidentielle seuls emmanuel mâcon fait
de l'europe un étendard de son programme
le candidat dans marche considère encore
l'union comme un acquis essentiel et
entend la renforcer pour construire une
communauté plus fédérale les autres
candidats de gauche comme de droite
entendent bien changé l'union européenne
certains prônent la sortie tandis que
d'autres plaident pour une refondation
du projet européen
marine le pen candidate du front
national appelle un référendum pour
sortir de leurs oeufs et rétablir les
frontières nationales
un discours partagé par nicolas dupont
aignan candidat de debout la république
partisan lui aussi d'un freak site sur
le modèle de nos voisins britanniques
françois fillon anciens partisans du non
à maastricht en 1992 souhaite une europe
à minima et réclament une réforme des
institutions européennes mais le leit
motiv de refonte de l'union n'est pas
l'apanage de la droite
la question européenne divise aussi à
gauche jean luc mélenchon leader de la
france est soumise
n'exclut pas de sortir de l'union
européenne s'il n'y a pas de
renégociation des traités
benoît hamon lui parle de réorienter
l'europe vers plus d'harmonisation
sociale et fiscale et milite pour une
assemblée parlementaire de la zone euro
et à quelques jours du premier tour
seule certitude pour les candidats
l'union européenne aujourd'hui est en
panne
[Musique]
marc tarabella on voit que le seul qui
soit capable de faire applaudir le
drapeau européen alors cette campagne
c'est emmanuel macron assia pas un
problème
non il ya aussi benoît hamon très
clairement je pense que l'on peut
s'inscrire dans ses propos moi je peux
le partage et le dire il faut évidemment
au niveau européen aujourd'hui le projet
est en panne il faut pas non plus cacher
les yeux face le projet européen est en
panne depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant on n'arrive plus à avancer
parce que les états membres son avantage
une dirait un ensemble de pays dont il
est difficile de trouver une cohésion
qui a des minorités de blocage qui
empêche souvent l'avancé donc clairement
à aller vers une harmonisation fiscale
et sociale aujourd'hui on a un marché
intérieur mais qui est aussi
problématique parce qu'il ya une telle
disparité qui génère une concurrence au
niveau salarial au niveau social qui
fait que ça devient assez invivable il
ne dit rien d'autre
et donc je plais c'est ce que dit
effectivement que l'europe n'a pas la
place qu'elles mériteraient dans le
débat français la france dès qu'on s'y
sent la campagne donc d' emmanuel macron
la france ne commettent pas comme l
erreur que ne commet pas l'allemagne
en allemagne ils savent où est l'intérêt
européen c'est le marché intérieur le
marché international l'environnement
l'industrie et tout ça passe par là et
paris est ici on a des collègues
évidemment très courageux français très
impliqué mais paris déconsidère l'europe
paris centralisme parisien à la france
souffre de ces énarques et de c2c aux
élites qui sont concentrées sur paris
paris n'est pas le centre du monde il
chante de l'europe est donc clairement
considérer l'europe comme étant vraiment
la possibilité d'intégrer mieux les
différents pays avec des stratégies
ce serait bien d'avoir un pendant à
madame merkel ou à monsieur toulouse
comme je peux le souhaitez dans quelques
mois évidemment
alors peut-être que est ce qu emmanuel
macron est le pendant de martin schulz
comme le disait sigmar gabriel donc qui
était à la tête du spd en allemagne il
ya encore quelques temps houleux pendant
que madame merkel bon disons que switch
en allemagne il a tout le parti derrière
lui ce qu'il contrairement à benoît
hamon pour lui et pour les autres
candidats aussi mais c'est vrai que
c'est un lange et c'est l'europe et
malheureusement on en discute pas assez
comme l'a parfaitement décliné marque
mais quand même c'est à une élection en
france et la france est un pays de
l'union européenne donc la question qui
sera que fera les candidats qui gagnent
avec la france en europe et là je pense
qu'il faut quand même avouer que la
france elle-même peut aussi changer les
affaires d'elle-même donc je re derguy a
été socialiste eut le rappelle à mon ami
marc tarabella 2 0 monsieur monsieur cru
l'ancien chancelier allemand avant
gallery
il ya 15 ans qui a changé l'allemagne et
du dernier deux derniers points en
europe au premier et donc on peut
changer l'histoire on peut changer aussi
le climat économique
si on le veut et a besoin de réformes en
france selon vous est ce que j'ai
apporté par les socialistes ou par l'est
républicain que je couvre la veux dire
c'est que c'est pas la faute à bruxelles
oui la faute pour en large partie de mon
point de vue c'est aussi en france donc
il faut que contrairement à wissous est
morte et dans l'ordre dans certains
discours en fait qu'ils disent
globalement que c'est la faute à
bruxelles c'est quoi la peur de
bruxelles david carretta c'est de voir
marine le pen arrivé au pouvoir
sûrement sûrement et malheureusement
bruxelles ne réagit pas il dit toujours
que la politique nationale est devenue
européenne et la politique européenne
est devenue nationale mais à la fin la
commission jean claude juncker
le conseil donald tout ce que le
président du parlement européen antonio
tajani ne disent pas ce qu'ils pensent
des élections françaises et ils ne
veulent pas prendre position
proposition prendre position a raconté
qu est-ce que c'est l'europe qu'est ce
que c'est la politique et aux veines il
ya un exemple un des grands thèmes de la
campagne les trois françaises c'est le
travailleur est taxé de quoi parle-t-on
on parle en france de plus ou moins 180
mille personnes travailleurs détachés
viennent d'autres pays mais la france
est aussi le troisième exportateur avec
près de 300 mille travailleurs détachés
qui travaillent dans toute l'europe
trois cent mille travailleurs français
détaché voilà et on parle de qui on
parle de personnes qui aident par
exemple les les personnages et qui
travaille dans la construction oui mais
pas seulement ça on part de gens qui
travaillent dans les hô pital et on
oublie de dire qu'ils que si on a ce
problème entre guillemets si on a des
violations des règles et européennes et
nationales
c'est pas à cause de l'europe mais à
cause de la france qui n'a pas un nombre
suffisant d'inspecteurs de travail et
leurs sources a par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'on fait comme choix on laisse tout
comme maintenant ou alors on peut
proposer la police et européennes où les
inspecteurs de travail européen de jean
claude juncker qui vont dans les états
membres
vérifiez si on reste quelques jours de
plus quelques jours de moins à la fin la
responsabilité c'est des états membres
politiciens nationale c'est de marine le
pen qui passe son temps ici dénoncé l'
europe l oubli de dénoncer ce qui fait
la france et même chose pour jean luc
mélenchon parce qu'ils sont très près
sur ces questions là est le problème de
mon comté observateurs journalistes
basée à bruxelles
c'est que l'europe à blick est aussi
dans son rôle de dire la vérité aux
français aux européens c'est le cas marc
tarabella andré achab l'europe abdiqué
sur ces questions sur la nécessité de
prendre position sur des questions
nationales
très clairement on souffre par exemple
une crise de valeurs en europe 1
aujourd'hui ce que fait monsieur urban
en hongrie je peux aussi critiqué le
social-démocrate qui robert fils sont en
slovaquie ce groupe devise grade qui
finalement sont des provocateurs mais
qui joue à la démocratie qui font
reculer les droits le droit à la liberté
de la presse le droit à la liberté
économique et on leur dit rien et les
traités ne permettent pas besoin
puisqu'il faut l'unanimité des états
membres pour éventuellement mettre sous
la loupe et donc de fait c'est facile de
dire dallas à la faute à bruxelles
puisque bruxelles finalement ne fait
rien pour sanctionner ceux qui
contreviennent aux valeurs fois aussi
paralysée par les règles qui sont
toujours les autres qui ne sont plus
adaptées à 28 pays et il faudrait sans
doute effectivement moi je n'aime pas
parler de changer les traités pourquoi
parce que sada plomberie et citoyens ne
sont pas intéressés par la plomberie
sont intéressés par les problèmes qui
les concernent et qui voudrait qu'on les
voit régler en reste faible la question
en fait de marine le pen potentiellement
en tête au premier tour voire la
question voyait il y a quelques jours la
presse allemande s'alarmer en fait une
possibilité d'accession au pouvoir de
marine le pen vous y croyez je n'y crois
pas mais on a on a des angoisses car le
risque est plus grande que jamais en 4
en 2001 le père de marine le pen avait
du mal 3% premier tour plus ou moins et
23% au deuxième tour cette fois ci elle
aura plus au deuxième tour et donc le
risque est plus grand
mais j'espère que pour l'europe et pour
la france qu'on peut éviter ça car quand
même le base de nos pays la france
l'allemagne la belgique et l'europe dans
un monde globalisé sait qu'on doit
travailler ensemble si on veut faire ce
qu'elle propose si on veut défendre nos
valeurs la seule chose qu'on peut faire
c'est de travailler ensemble
seul on sera perdue à mon avis c'est une
occasion cette élection pourquoi parce
que finalement après le référendum de
2005 sur la constitution européenne
les français pourront à nouveau choisir
les europe au palais europe que ce soit
à mélenchon le pen on n'est pas sortis
en fait de ce débat de 2005 a été ouvert
par la fracture de il se réfère à
d'abord figé peut-être c'est une
occasion pour le résoudre
ou en tout cas pour clarifier les choses
et c'est important parce que la
démocratie c'est aussi clarifier les
choix des gens par rapport à une
question fondamentale comme l'europe
ça va être les peines à mettra fin de
l'europe et les français vont prendre
cette responsabilité
ça va être ma cran fillaut peut-être
benoît hamon c'est peut-être pas la fin
de l'europe mais pour relancer l'europe
il faut il faut la défendre
il faut l'aimer il faut reconnaître que
c'est un projet difficile mais qui peut
avancer
vous êtes d'accord absolument alors il
ya une autre polémique qui a occupé les
médias il y a depuis quelques semaines
c'est la clause molière dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler la clause
molière c'est une clause qui oblige en
fait sur les chantiers à parler français
alors certains certaines régions qui
l'ont adopté disent que c'est une
question de sécurité
ça a été un petit peu ému au niveau
européen notamment marianne thyssen qui
est la commissaire chargé de l'emploi et
qui est belge
et justement c'est l'heure du checkpoint
de thomas mignon et thomas mignon s'est
posé la question de savoir si c'était
illégal ou non le checkpoint s'est tout
de suite
[Musique]
la clause molière était illégal
vis-à-vis de l'europe
la commissaire à l'emploi la belge
marianne thyssen a laissé entendre dans
un entretien accordé au parisien
sur le plan juridique dit elle je pense
que cette clause est une discrimination
contraire à la législation européenne
tout d'abord la clause molière c'est
quoi c'est une disposition qui vise à
imposer l'usagé du français sur les
chantiers publics
le principe est de garantir la sécurité
grâce à une bonne communication entre
travailleurs mais l'objectif assumé est
aussi de lutter contre les travailleurs
détachés et le topping sociale bien que
contesté cette clause molière a déjà été
adopté par plusieurs régions et
départements de france l'application de
la clause cie traduirait par une mention
dans les appels d'offres et serait
désormais un critère d'attribution des
marchés publics
mais est-elle contraire à la législation
européenne
pour le savoir il faut se tourner vers
la charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne un important texte
qui définit les valeurs communes de
l'union à l'article 21 de cette
déclaration on peut lire est interdit
toute discrimination fondée notamment
sur la langue
cet article et par extension cette
charte ne sont donc pas respectés par la
fameuse clause molière puisqu'elle
impose le français au détriment des
autres langues
mais cette charte est l contraignant ce
texte a la même valeur juridique que le
traité de lisbonne
autrement dit il peut être juridiquement
contraignant du moins à certaines
conditions
elle s'applique pleinement aux
institutions de l'union européenne et
aux états membres mais uniquement
lorsqu'il met en oeuvre le droit de
l'union
claude moly à pourrait théoriquement
être considérée comme une mise en oeuvre
biaisée du droit de la protection des
travailleurs et côté européen on ne
tranche pas ou du moins pas encore en
attendant cette clause est elle
contraire à la législation européenne en
partie
alors mais si on revient on l'a vu sur
encore ces travailleurs détachés soit
vous choque marque talabot tarabella
cette clause molière qu'on l'a mis en
oeuvre dans plusieurs régions de france
c'est très choquant
ouais populisme de bas étage venant de
droite évidemment pour répondre à un
problème qui existe peut-être moi si mon
père savait sur politiciens belges
avaient dû inventer cette clause en 1955
mon père mais je n'aurais jamais pu
venir d'italie vont travailler en
belgique est donc clairement autant je
peux comprendre que quand sur un
chantier public il doit y avoir un
interlocuteur qui parlent la langue des
citoyens en cas de sécurité c'est vrai
hein
c'est peut-être le chef du chantier
c'est peut-être le directeur des travaux
à un moment donné il ya des pénuries de
main d'oeuvre dans certains pays pour
certains travaux et je ne crois pas qu
on hésite parce que l'article
la charte des droits fondamentaux il est
clair et donc c'est en contradiction
avec la charte soit de vrais doit
attaquer la france enfin en l'occurrence
ces régions françaises qui applique
cette clause monnaire oui les marchés
publics il ya des lois et européens
donc c'est clair que c'est pas en ligne
avec le droit européen même si nous
aimons beaucoup
molière ça je pense que tout le monde
est d'accord
david carretta on a quelque chose de
similaire qui a été mis en oeuvre ou pas
en italie
ça n'existe pas on a quelque chose de
semblable en flanc en belgique par
exemple où on essaie d'imposer le
flamand tout le monde ou de ne pas faire
arriver les étrangers en un an pesant la
langue pour acheter une maison pour
prendre la résidence dans certaines
communes on est à lyon là quelque chose
de semblable on a une sorte de clause
spaghetti dans les centres d
bâle ville historique italienne il ya
des mères qui disent on peut pas ouvert
des restaurants ethniques
donc c'est disons le nettoyage culinaire
le nettoyage linguistique le nettoyage
culinaire il faut faire attention parce
que c'est une façon de comment dire
imposer un nettoyage ethnique
il est vrai que culturel en passant par
la porte derrière on le fait en italie
on le fait en finlande on risque de le
faire en france et c'est très dangereux
parce que là on revient en arrière pas
seulement avec l'europe mais aussi avec
les progrès que nos états membres n'ont
pays ont fait ouais c'est 60 ans après
le traité drame effectivement cela fait
un peu désordre
et je dois vous dire sans les
restaurants italiens l'allemagne serait
en panne et strasbourg aussi et la
france aussi
merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'est la fin de
cette émission
mais pas de panique vous pouvez revoir
cette émission sur les sites des chaînes
parlementaires et de la rtbf qui diffuse
bien entendu cette émission la semaine
prochaine vous retrouverez ahmed tazir
depuis bruxelles très belle semaine à
tous ciao
[Musique]